it's always funny when I see it I'm like
wo it's so a lot it's very it's very a
lot but I don't ever see it I look in
the mirror I'm like I can't see it ala
GQ I'm here to take you through some of
my
[Music]
tat they really talk about like these
things live inside of you and you're
just like touching it to like bring it
out I don't crave it as much as like I'm
called to it I've never felt like oh I
need to get that on me it's always been
like well this needs to happen or this
it's like through definitive moments
that needed to happen in my life and it
just feels like more of a calling than
uh than me choosing stuff and just
putting random on my body the first
tattoo was uh this one right here took
about 8 hours it's amaka it's a guardian
and that's the shark it's the mono I had
this done right before my daughter was
born so I was 26 when I had this on 44
now that was my first tattoo pretty
gnarly cuz it's the biggest one I have
and it's the first one I did so I did it
this extension of it for this character
that I'm playing on on chief of War it
really fit with that so I've only really
worn this with one character right right
now the next one I do on Minecraft it
will have to be covered up I didn't
originally do this all the way down
because I wasn't making it as an actor
this was for me and you know you don't
want to have a bunch of tattoos on it
you're not going to get a lot of jobs
and
then now that I'm me I can have the
things that I'd like to have now so I'm
very thankful for that I guess when we
did the dth rocky stuff I it's funny
because they wanted to cover this up and
they always had like long bands but I
was like guys there's tapestry behind me
that has this design on it why wouldn't
it and they're like we don't want your
tattoo so I was like fine and then when
I did these just sitting in the makeup
trailer and I just become obsessed with
all that kind of stuff when you're
building a character so I just kind of
came over that I came up putting all the
black around my eyes you just get
obsessed with playing a character and I
just enjoy that when they design the
sets they're amazing and they're not
blue screen when you actually get to
walk into those sets you're like wow you
you you're it's beautiful to coexist
with these other artists and then
wardrobe and props and you get to see
all these things and you get to bring
your work in with their work and yeah
you feel huge when I put on Aquaman it's
like there's no doubt about it when I'm
in the suit the eyes go in I could just
be talking to you and then I'll step out
and come back in and I'll just look at
you and you're just
like like no eye contact it's like
looking at like a pitol staring at you
you know I don't really act Regal at all
so you know there's a certain thing when
you put on something you want to change
the way you feel and very important that
wardrobe and makeup and love makeup
obviously sorry
Jen Charles B
quote which was always be drunken with
wine with poetry with virtue with the
idea of always being happy and being
intoxicated with life I'm pretty giddy
about life so it made sense pride of
gypsies it's just my handwriting of
shitty handwriting so it's just all when
you like what does that mean with those
scratches that's just my handwriting and
so pride of gypsies because a lot of my
friends were Leos and they are lions and
we were all very houseless I should say
and I still am so we just kind of always
moving and very nomadic lifestyle of
filming and um obviously joining the
circus as an actor it just kind of felt
appropriate for our production company
there's two other people that have pride
of gypsies my other two partners Brian
mza and Thomas Paul on the ram a lot of
my team has the on the Rome and that's
turned into what it is now this is like
a core what it all started with and on
the ram now is um most of my team and
they have those tattoos the O the T it's
like the Cross Roads and then Ro on each
Direction This Rome and I have a show
about that and I use it for a lot of
other things this one right here is uh
Diablo which is after my I guess one of
the most important men I've ever known
and the most impactful man uh he died at
like 81 I want to say 82 that's what we
call him El L Diablo and he was amazing
and so it's just those mentors that
you you meet and he's one of those
people that just blew my whole mind and
uh well read could just talk for hours
and just enjoyed every moment just
sitting with him talking also got my
children the most important I saved
their name when they first wrote their
name Lola and wolf so I saved that cuz
obviously they were different in age so
I just saved hers and then saved his and
put it together so Lola wolf on my on my
heart I have tons of friends with just
the most random crazy and that
perfectly describes them and that's
what's great about tattoos they little
giggles and laughs and silly things but
yeah these all just been the right
calling to do it oh yeah there we go the
one I never get to see it's always funny
when I see it I'm like wo it's so a lot
it's very it's very a lot but I don't
ever see it and I look in the mirror I'm
like I can't see it it always looks
pretty intense when you're like jeez
Louise these were all tapped so all the
Hawaiian ones are tapped the traditional
way it has the eaz right here there a
protection one right here it's almost
like a tridon but that's for protection
eaz the spear I'd rather have it tapped
I think it's pretty beautiful cuz you're
going back you know centuries of of
humans being you know making tat on
themselves or moku on themselves and
that's the sound that they heard it's
like t t t t t and it's a beautiful
interesting sound it doesn't sound like
like an annoying buzzing gun sound and
it just it feels so different I feel
like the gun is really like taking a
fork and like scraping your skin instead
of like when you feel that tap it's it
can cover more ground you know mean cuz
there's different lengths and sizes of
them so I think it probably moves a
little bit faster I think if you're
going to have Precision in them they're
different like if with these when you
get them tapped they'll be like the
worst they've ever looked with gun I
feel like that's the best it's ever
going to look because it'll eventually
bleed out and all that kind of stuff
what it's designed with this is that
you'll have spaces but it will over time
fill that out and if it's done right by
a master it'll only get better and
better my uncle Keon Nunes is someone
who rescued our culture and and then
perpetuated and traces our genealogy so
my father has like a whole piece that
goes down his leg that he waited till
he's probably 50 to do so I'll have to
get that at some point and then have
another one that goes on the chest
that'll probably do it I mean I I've
never experienced anything on on that
level before that was it was really
beautiful and purifying and and and like
I've never had that kind of pain before
from here to here was was you you get to
meet your ancestors for sure you get to
meet all of them my auntie momy who's
like loveing my life my uncle Buffalo I
did at his house um the moments where I
really needed help the most I could just
hear her laughing in the background just
doing who she is and then out of nowhere
this hand goes into my mouth cuz I'm
like just breathing through it so much
intense pain like where your every poure
in every socket is just using water to
like survive she put salt and pcket in
my mouth and you just taste those those
beautiful crystals of salt and it
totally like rescued me and she just
knew and that's what the the elders like
she really saved me in that moment and
the nice thing about this is it just
hair goes back and it's gone and it's
for me you know it when it's shaved like
this you can see it but when it's not
I'm like you're just covering up a
little bit on my
neck
I don't have any regrets regretting it's
not going to help me now just where I'm
at and did I learn from it yeah I
did so they're all beautiful
[Music]
lessons